for many this is the front line of the
cost of living crisis
the spiraling price of buying or renting
the roof over your head as bills of all
kind are increasing too
owning rather than renting a home can
make a massive difference for those on
the lowest incomes
andrew has benefited from a pilot scheme
that gave him the right to buy his
housing association home winning and
also security
the issue is is
some rules and regulations change and as
i've heard here say of
they were talking about because my
children are growing up now i've got a
three-bedroomed house
that they might want to move me into a
one-bedroom flat
even though this is a home for the
children the kids come back here
hopefully one of their grandkids will as
well
and i just want to keep the property and
this is a guaranteed way of keeping the
property now because i bought it they
can't turn around and say we need to
transfer you to a flat
it's great
boris johnson in blackpool today and in
need of a political rebuild expanding
the right to buy pilot scheme the first
building block
and with it a promise of more precision
engineering to bring down costs
this is a speech designed to appeal to
his rebellious backbenchers as much as
the public it's time for the government
to stop spending and to start cutting
taxes and cutting regulation sometimes
the best way the government can help
is simply to get out of the way
to do less or to do it better or simply
and not at all the pm covered everything
from tax cuts to olive tariffs to
closing ticket offices
but eventually got to his second big
housing plan i can announce a
comprehensive review of the mortgage
market reporting back this autumn it
will look at how we can give our nation
of aspiring homeowners better access to
low deposit mortgages and a promise to
refocus
uh that we will be able to get on with
the mission on which this government was
elected to unite and level up across our
country
so that no matter where you are born or
what your background we will give you
the chance to fulfill your potential
boris johnson's big argument here today
is that the government cannot spend its
way out of the cost of living crisis so
he wants to reform to cut costs today
housing soon child care and transport
but to deliver meaningful change he's
going to need unity from his cabinet and
the party and mps are going to be
looking to see whether the country is
with them
[Applause]
business owners suffer at work and at
home this restaurant opened months ago
the manager says rising prices means
fewer customers and less money for the
family at the end of the day
everything has gone up
absolutely everything we cannot put the
prices high up because we're gonna end
up closing the shop so
we're trying to survive the best we can
behind the arcades blackpool is one of
the most deprived parts of the country
boris johnson promised long-term wins
for the lucky few but in places like
this not everyone can afford to wait
their turn
samcote sky news blackpool